t
le dernier chiffre. Il promet
qu'on va se rendre à zéro
bientôt. On a parlé au ministre
plutôt mes reportages de
Charlotte Dumoulin.
- C'est la rentrée scolaire
la plus normale depuis deux ans.
Les élèves voient des sourires,
peuvent se tenir par la main.
L'école en ligne et les masques
leur semblent déjà loin.
- C'est moins stressant
que l'année passée, oui.
- C'est toujours excitant
avec notre enfant de la voir
sa première journée.
- J'ai hâte de rencontrerma nou.
- Mais le manque d'enseignants
et de professionnels de soutien
assombrit la première journée.
Le matin de la rentrée,
400 postes à temps plein
et à temps partiel sont toujours
vacants à Montréal.
Des orthopédagogues sont
temporairement relocalisés,
plus d'enseignants
non légalifiés
sont embauchés.
ISABELLE GELINAS, dg, Centre de
services scolaire de Montréal
- Tout le monde a minimalement
un adulte devant la classe.
Puis là, actuelle
on se sert de notre banque
de suppléants pour s'assurer
qu'il y a un bon service
qui est offert aux élèves.
- Depuis plusieurs années,
ignants non légalement
qualifiés sont une solution
à la pénurie. Ils doivent
au moins avoir un baccalauréat.
Or, avec la gravité
de la situation à la rentrée,
le Centre de services scolaire
de Montréal doit même faire
appel à des moniteurs de camp
pour desonctuels.
L'Alliance des professeurs
de Montréal sonne l'alarme.
CATHERINE BEAUVAIS-ST-PIERRE,
prés. Alliance prof. de Montréal
- On est en mode solution pour
éteindre le feu, donc on cherche
à la dernière minute commententt
combler les trous.
- Les défis de rétention
dans les écoles de Montréal
sont pires qu'ailleurs,
ajoute-t-elle.
- La pénurie enseignante,
c'est un gros cercle vicieux.
À Montréal, c'est un cercle
vicieux qui dure depuis
longtemps et qui,
malheureusement, risque de durer
encore, même si on réussit
à apaiser la pénurie ailleurs
au Québec.
- Bonne journée d'école
les amis!
- Près de 600 postes
de personnel enseignant
à temps plein sont à pourvoir
dans les écoles du Québec.
Ici Charlotte Dumoulin,